this episode of fun science is brought
to you by Squarespace do you wish you
could just get away from it all
searching for a new lease on life a
change of scenery do you hear the call
to adventure well if so you'll love Mars
life on Earth getting to your head then
visit the planet where everything's red
we got big rocks small rocks everything
you need rocks interested then just give
us a ring on Mars
pour me one two three that's Mars for me
one two three terms and conditions apply
please note all messages sent to Mars
take approximately 14 minutes to reach
the planet spacesuit and potatoes not
included seriously please please come
I'm the only one here they don't even
have tea here or or anything on the
surface Mars is fairly unremarkable I
mean literally just look at this photo
of the surface of Mars if you had to
mistake it for a desert here on earth on
an overcast day pretty sure no one would
blame you so why is it that we humans
seem so obsessed with this little red
planet and it is little by the way
there's a common misconception that
Earth and Mars are around the same
diameter but in reality Mars is around
half as wide as Earth and yet we have
attempted around 50 missions to Mars
since 1960 which is more than any other
planet in the solar system besides Earth
so why do we keep coming back to it well
in order to answer that question let's
go back in time for as long as our
species has been around we've been able
to look up at the night sky and see a
little red dot the planet Mars it's
thought the people used to associate its
reddish color with bloodshed and war
which is why it's named after Mars the
Roman god of war Mars is red color
doesn't really have anything to do with
blood of course but actually comes from
the iron oxide on the planet's surface
and in its atmosphere you might actually
have seen iron oxide before although
here on earth it's often referred to as
rust so Mars is red because it's rusty
so humans have been observing Mars for a
long long time there are recorded
observations going all the way back to
ancient Egypt whose astronomers noted
precisely how the planet
throughout the night sky by the 1800s
the resolution of telescopes reached the
point where astronomers such as Giovanni
Schiaparelli were just about able to
make out the surface features of the
planets however unfortunately the images
these telescopes produced weren't quite
good enough for Giovanni to clearly see
what Mars looked like and so he and
other astronomers started to see
features on the planet that simply
weren't there
Giovanni called them Canali which
translates to channels however this was
actually mistranslated to the canals of
Mars and as here on earth canals are
man-made they were thought by some to be
evidence that the planet Mars was
populated by an intelligent life now it
was this idea of possible life on Mars
that led British writer HG Wells to
write his famous novel War of the Worlds
which featured one of the first
depictions of a Martian invasion since
then we've seen a vast amount of stories
centering on the idea that there might
be life on the planet but the topic of
life on Mars is not just one for science
fiction to tell us more we now go live
to our reporter in the field Susan are
you there yes hello earth
I'm here on actual Mars to bring you an
exclusive interview with the resident
Martian the Curiosity rover curiosity
how are you doing today pretty children
thanks for having me let's get right to
it
what my life need in order to sustain
itself here on Mars great cue dude so as
far as we know if you want to have life
you're gonna have water okay sure but
there's no water on Mars is there well
we actually do have water here though
Wow I think that might be a fun science
exclusive there's water on Mars
it's so you're a little late to the
party on that front though oh but that's
just ice though right
that doesn't count you've never had a
life there it's not like flowing water
or anything okay so two things number
one we definitely have flowing water
here in the form of occasional liquid
brian's beneath the soil and number two
if there is life on mars it's probably
chilean deep beneath those polar ice
caps so get your facts straight brah wow
that's amazing
so one last quickfire question is there
life on Mars yes or no I think this
interview is over dude well there you
have it everyone there may or may not be
life on Mars we really have no idea back
to you in the studio
I went poorly didn't it how much did we
spend to send them there thanks so much
for that great report now of course one
way we'll know for sure that there is
life on Mars is if that life is us but
will humans ever really go to Mars or
possibly even settle there well NASA is
currently aiming to complete a manned
mission to Mars in the 2030s the most
recently announced trip would be onboard
the deep-space transport which would
bring four humans to Mars although
instead of landing on the planet it
would just orbit it and then return
there are however some private plans for
humans to settle on Mars such as Mars 1
and Elon Musk's interplanetary transport
system musk is actually planning on a
permanent Mars landing in 2025 which
would eventually lead to a full
colonization of the entire planet which
brings us back neatly to today's main
question why Mars
honestly Mars is the nearest restroom
planet to us with conditions vaguely
similar to those on earth unlike Venus
and Mercury which would be far more
likely to kill us if we aware to try
exploring them
so basically when it comes to visiting
other planets Mars is pretty much our
only option
yeah bars see you next time let's say
that you decided to go and live on Mars
you'd probably want an easy way to keep
your friends and family back on earth
up-to-date with all your Martian antics
right which case you'd probably want to
build your own website I personally use
Squarespace partly because it's been
recommended to me a thousand times and
ads like this one but mostly because it
does make building a great looking
website credibly easy to do if you're
looking to make your next move and share
your ideas with the people of Earth why
not start your free trial today and go
to Squarespace com forward slash fun
science to get 10% off your first
purchase also if you'd like to support
fun science directly and help us make
more episodes just like this why not
consider becoming a patron of the show
just go to patreon.com/scishow is
information thanks a lot guys